So let's kick off with the foliage tool settings and to do that I'm going to jump inside my
editor and with my editor open I'm going to go into the foliage mode. So you can find
the foliage mode at the top left and we'll just go to foliage. You'll see the hotkey
is shift 3. So if you want to hit shift and 3 on your keyboard you could also do that
and you'll see that we have this new window pop up for the foliage. So we can essentially
add any static mesh for foliage type we want into this tool and all we have to do is just drag
the asset from the content browser which is down here into this foliage section. You can see this
big text here saying drop foliage here. So we'll just go into our mesh and we'll get a bush mesh
and we'll just drag and drop that in there and I'll give myself a bit more real estate here. And so
you can see that we're preparing us for foliage shaders. You can see that we've got this bush
selected here and you'll see now when we go into our browser you can see the painting tool. So we
can if we left click here you'll see that we've painted some bushes and it's interesting to know
if I'm just going to select mode now you'll see that we've got 41 actors and that was 41 bush
meshes placed on that stroke. And so since we painted that foliage we just want to go in and
sculpt our landscape. We can just left click wherever we would like and you can also shift
and left click to remove foliage. So if I went back into the paint tool and I held down shift
I could left click and that deletes some and you'll see that that number has gone down.
So we've got a little save icon here where you can save the foliage assets and whether it's you
know active or not. So if you toggle this on and off it depends whether that foliage is selected.
So let's take a look at exactly what all these settings do. So I've loaded up a screenshot of
exactly what you'll see in the foliage tool as we saw in the engine there and I just wanted to go
over some of the settings here. So we've got the selection tool and that's used to select
individual instances, all instances, deselect, we can lasso select. You can see all of these
different settings for selection inside of your foliage settings. We've also got the paint tool
which is used for adding and removing foliage instances from the world as you just saw.
We've got the reapply tool which is used to change the parameters of instances already painted in the
world. We've got the single tool that's used to place a single instance of the selected foliage
using the paintbrush. We've also got the fill tool which is used to determine the number of meshes
to place with the paint tool. Erase tool pretty self-explanatory but it's used to erase
selected foliage. We've got the remove tool which removes the selected foliage and we've got move
which moves the foliage to a different level. You may be using less of this tool in the more
recent versions of Unreal Engine. It depends if you're changing levels as much with your foliage
but it's still useful to know that. So the paint and brush options will have different options based
on the tool selected and the filters then allow you to select which items you want from the foliage
to be used on. So there's loads more settings that you'll see covered. You'll see that brush sizes,
density, all quite self-explanatory and it's more about just playing around with these different
settings to get the results that you want. We can also change the mesh as you saw when we were
painting the mesh. You can see that the static mesh is found here so what we can also do once
the objects are placed allowing you to quickly change and not having to rework it. So if you
wanted to update that mesh and you didn't want to go in and paint everything again you could easily
do that with the mesh update there. We also have the painting settings where we've got the density
and we've got the radius but then we've also got scaling where we could change minimax values.
Say you wanted some variation in your foliage size for example you could set the minimax to
say 0.5 and 2 and you could get varying degrees of foliage so it just didn't feel like the same
repeating action over and over. So the paint tools do allow you to control how many objects are placed
and then the radius helps just make sure things are not intersecting so that that radius setting
there just makes sure that you can either clump things densely together or really really space
them out a lot more. We've also got the placement settings where placement allows you to control
how the meshes are aligned to the surface area applied to so you can offset the vertical position
up and down if you wanted to add some variation like you can see in this image here so
you can give a max angle height and a max angle and height sorry that can be then applied.
We've also got the instant settings here so instant settings essentially control how the foliage
reacts to lighting, collision and culling so you can set if you want the foliage to use a light map
or not it depends if you're using fully dynamic solutions like lumen. We can also set the distance
at which the foliage should stop rendering and then lastly to cover some further settings we've
got scalability settings here and that allows you to work the foliage with the scalability setting
system built into unreal so this allows the system to control the foliage settings based on
whatever user settings you may have set. We also have the physics so this is a physical material
override that allows you to apply it to the foliage so physical materials could be used for certain
surface parameters such as if you wanted it to be slippy ice or gravel but it also can be used to
detect say footstep sounds and just different parameters you want when you're walking through
foliage to change maybe the player's behavior. We do have the virtual texture here and that's
for any foliage that you wish to draw to the virtual texture and then the h-lod which do you
want to include them in their h-lod calculations there.